We all need things.
We need food, water, and air.
We need a home and clothing, too.
We all want things.
We want things that make us happy.
We want things that are fun.
Erin needs water to drink.
She needs a glass of lemonade.
Jacob needs food to eat.
He wants pasta for dinner.
Erin needs a warm coat for the winter.
She wants a long red coat.
Jacob needs air to breathe.
He wants some wind to fly his kite.
Erin needs to stay safe from the storm.
She wants to go under her bed.
Jacob needs a way to get to school.
He wants a new bike.
Erin needs to read a book for school.
She wants to read a funny book.
What kinds of things do you want?
Do you really need those things?